what exactly is probability well let's
just take a simple example like a hat if
you have a hat and there's three marbles
in there two red and one blue what's the
probability that I reach into this hat
and I pick a red marble well when you
think of probability it's the number of
successful outcomes divided by the total
possible outcomes in other words I like
to think of it as what you want divided
by the total things that could occur so
in this case we want a red marble so
there's two chances of getting a red
marble out of a total of three possible
marbles so the probability would be
two-thirds of picking a red marble and
you could write that as P of R like the
probability of a red marble so let's get
into some other examples here so the
first one you can see we've got a line
segment here okay we've got some points
on the line segment ABCD but it's asking
us what's the probability that if we
pick a point at random on this line
segment okay that's am blind foil and
just pick a point what's the probability
that we lie we pick a point that lie
somewhere in between B and C so right
here well now in this problem what we're
thinking about is the length of success
divided by the total length okay whereas
over here we are counting the number of
successes out of the total possible here
we're considering the length of success
meaning that the length that we want out
of the total length so in this case you
can see it's one two three okay so three
units okay divided by a total length of
you can see eight units so our
probability is going to be 3/8 and you
can write probability as a fraction or a
decimal or if it says what's the percent
chance then you could convert it into a
percentage but probability in general is
between zero and one zero meaning no
chance one meaning a hundred percent
chance of success now example two now
we're moving from one dimension to two
dimensions we're talking about area and
it's asking us what's the probability
that you pick a point at random inside
of this rectangle then it lies in this
shaded region okay outside of the circle
okay so again what we want to think
about is what do we want well we want
the area of success okay the area of
success which is the shaded area divided
by the total area
okay let's talk about this area of
success so to get this shaded region
we're gonna take the total area which is
10 times 20 that's 200 - we're going to
subtract off this circle well you can
see that the diameter of the circle is
10 which means that the radius is going
to be 5 which means we're subtracting PI
R square which is pi times 5 squared so
that gives us the shaded region now
we're going to divide by the total area
which is the rectangle 20 times 10 which
is 200 so let's go to the calculator
let's seeyou approximately what that
comes out - we've got 200 minus 5
squared is 25 times pi so 25 pi let's
see here
it's 121 approximately divided by 200 so
it's coming out to about 0.6 1 or in
other words about a 61% chance but the
probability is 0.61 now the third
example before I get into that one in
three dimensions I just want to mention
that if you're preparing for that a CT
or the SAT check out my huge a CT math
review video course and my huge SAT math
review video course we go through a lot
of examples together a lot of formulas a
lot of things that you would likely see
on the exam and how to approach those
types of problems so check out some of
the free previews that are available see
if it's right for you a lot of students
have taken those courses and benefited
they said that they've improved their
overall scores so check that out and
let's get into this example 3 though if
you want to talk about the volume now
okay we're talking about the volume of
success divided by the total volume in
this case it's asking us what's the
probability if we pick a point in this
cylinder at random what's the
probability that that point lies inside
of one of these spheres okay so here
when we're talking about the volume of
success we're talking about the volume
of one of these spheres times three
since there's three of them okay so it's
kind of like tennis balls inside about
you know a cylinder right well let's see
the formula for volume of a sphere is
4/3 PI R cubed the diameter is 8 so that
means that the radius of one of these
spheres is 4 so this is 4/3 pi times 4
cubed but remember we have three of them
okay three spheres so that represents
the volume of success and we want to
divide it by the total volume which is
the volume of the cylinder now remember
the volume of a cylinder it's the area
of the base which is PI R squared times
the height which is 24 so let's see if
we can simplify this down a little bit
the 3s are going to cancel and then here
we've got let's see this is going to be
a four to the fourth times pi all right
that's the numerator and then in the
denominator 24 is like four times six so
that's going to be 4 squared times 4
which is 4 cubed times 6 to the first
times pi and then you can see the PI's
are cancelling three of these fours
cancel with three of these 4 is leaving
one left over so we end up getting 4
divided by 6 which is equal to 2/3 so
that's our probability of picking a
point at random in here and that you end
up inside of the sphere so I hope this
helped you know how to understand
working with geometric probability
better subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon